guau qué emoción fuerte saben que hay
muchas cosas que nos ponemos para poner
indicaciones no quitan los zapatos
porque quiero sentir esto me encanta
estoy lleno de mucha emoción
y la primera lección que yo obtuve
dentro del emprendimiento era justamente
rodearme de gente más inteligente que yo
y hoy voy a pisar el culito rojo se
siente bien gente talentosa
muy bien por la gente talentosa me
encanta incluso el talento es gratis y
se puede obtener
solo es disciplina y algunos hábitos y
demás
cuando empecé el emprendimiento yo
imaginaba un emprendedor
grande fuerte con una capa al viento y
así es como nos vemos así es como
empezamos sencillos con ideas queremos
ser escuchados
muchas veces no encontramos respuestas y
algunas veces pueden ser objetivas y
positivas pero yo creo que el
emprendimiento estoy seguro que es el
conjunto de resultados
los positivos puede contarles muchos y
serán muy buenos y nos vamos a reír
mucho tiempo pero los negativos y el
fracaso debe ser parte de tu vocabulario
el fracaso también viene con la
experiencia el fracaso el fracaso
acompaña a un emprendedor
y pues bueno para eso para el fracaso me
pinto de colores
soy contador público bueno eso dice el
título
como contador soy malísimo no me
encargue su contabilidad
luego ejército como fiscalista de las
mejores firmas en méxico tampoco
qué hacemos durante seguir intentando me
empecé en el de conocimiento y yo lo que
dije en mis fracasos es que hasta para
fracasar hay que hacerlo con pasión
hay que hacerlo con entregas con
entusiasmo hay que pegarle duro y hay
que pegarle bonito
incluso muchas personas podrán opinar tu
medio puede ser adverso
las palabras de las personas pueden ser
hirientes o incluso podrían guardar tu
objetivo no te dejes avanzar incluso
escuché al señor odín dupeyrón te le
mando saludos y escuché que había un
ponente para ser un cantante de ópera
y él decía es que amo cantar de verdad
amo cantar y quiero cantar pues no
puedes cantar porque tus capacidades
físicas no son las adecuadas para que
puedas cantar sabes que completo unos
iris de ópera y es todo lo que vas a
hacer
cada juego está atentando contra
cualquier emprendedor
vete al
seguramente no voy a ser el mejor
cantante pero a lo mejor con pasión
fracasando con pasión a lo mejor el
miedo a pararme o para dar una
conferencia como esta
y no sabemos el pasión la pasión a dónde
nos va a llevar lo intenta lo intenta lo
compasión siéntelo los emprendimientos
sienten
y mucho
si eran los ojos déjate llevar
ahora en mi experiencia en este programa
de canal son y que orgullosamente pude
pude presentar mi pitch
hay un túnel y al final hay unas puertas
y me decían qué vas a hacer si las
puertas se abren y tú calles
y seguramente hará rating para la tele
no será muy chistoso verme como caigo
[Risas]
y eso estaba bien dije seguramente
también para caerme también me puedo
levantar con estilo y puede ser una gran
ventaja
puedes ver hacia atrás ver tus errores y
rebotar
y eso me encantó y también me preguntaba
algún algún emprendedor esférico cómo le
haces para nadar entre tiburones mis
socios actuales son empresarios exitosos
y demás a los cuales le agradezco la
oportunidad y el conocimiento y la
experiencia que han mostrado y la
paciencia para poder educar a la nueva
camada de emprendedores y si yo tengo
por provisión lo mismo yo les resumía en
una sola en una sola parte que para para
ser un tiburón primero empiezas por
fingir ser un tiburón voy a fingir que
soy un tiburón y del hábito nace un
tiburón pero en la primer duda en la
primera el primer cuestionamiento ese
tiburón se voltea
y te muerde
en este caso le ponemos metafóricamente
tiburón
el talento el talento es el inicio para
poder emprender el talento está
disponible para todos el talento no es
innato no es un don el dios no te toca
te dice vas a tener talento el talento
se puede crear se puede adquirir con tus
conocimientos con tu capacidad con tu
disciplina con tus hábitos comer bien
hacer ejercicio leer dedicarte a ti
mismo el amor propio y por ahí me
preguntaban hoy efe y este y qué haces
tú para para que la gente no te vea la
cara o como proteger o como protege un
negocio
es igual que con tu persona si te amas
el amor propio lo predicas todos los
días igual que el emprendimiento
seguramente tú defenderá de la mejor
forma el emprendimiento que tienes y qué
estás haciendo puedes contratar el mejor
abogado te podría dar la mejor la mejor
fórmula para que todo fuera un resultado
pero igual te podría quitar la
experiencia de vivirlo
es así como siento es así cómo
debe o quieres deberías de querer hacer
y llamar lo que estás entendiendo y
hacerlo con fuerza y compasión bien
después de todas esas palabras misión
feijóo deja ser ridiculeces y deja estar
dando conferencias y pláticas y demás y
todo porque te pones a estudiar porque
si no vas a terminar vendiendo asadores
eso es en papá hoy qué razón tenía tu
terminé vendimiadores pero les y le hice
caso porque mira vendí asadores estoy
vendiendo asadores 1 por 10 2 por 20 3
por 34 por 40 no está complicado
pero también pude estudiar
hoy estoy muy orgulloso renovamos un
producto tradicional mexicano el anafre
estoy muy orgulloso mi socio que tiene
80 años emprendiendo conmigo teniendo la
confianza de hacerlo con un chavito o
con mucha borro contagias
y compasión donde se depositan los
valores a los afectos le doy muchas
gracias a mi socio y de los demás por
confiar en mí y hoy tenemos el mejor
asador del mundo porque si enciende
mantiene ahorra y se desempeña como debe
hacerse un asador entonces seguramente
tienes un asador a mi marca
aquí hay dos lecciones que me gustaría
compartirles
y es una de las cosas con pasión aunque
te equivoques no importa no sabemos algo
nos va a llevar y dos para todos los
nuevos emprendedores
la capacitación no es opcional es tu
obligación los servicios o los productos
que tú tienes incluso pueden salvar
vidas
hazlo de una manera responsable muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]